we've been talking about Donald Trump's
outrageous budget plan this is an issue
that's been somewhat overshadowed over
the last couple of weeks with scandal
after scandal at the White House we've
also talked in the past about how if
Republicans want to avoid a democratic
filibuster and pass a budget they're
going to have to minimize the effect of
their plan on the deficit so Donald
Trump's aspirations for this gigantic
tax cut and big spending on the military
infrastructure a border wall you're
going to have to offset that somehow now
part of this as we talked about
yesterday is this imaginary two trillion
dollars in revenue from economic growth
that will at some point happen and that
by the way they're counting twice
embarrassing I talked about that
yesterday let's put that aside for a
second how else are Republicans going to
pay for the hugely deficit increasing
tax cuts for the rich Republicans aren't
on board with creating new taxes like
value-added taxes or carbon taxes so
that's out Republicans aren't supporting
the removal of charitable and mortgage
interest deduction so that's out so
they're going to have to find some way
to cut 400 billion in spending somewhere
instead of the House Budget Committee
deciding what to cut they're telling
individual committees to figure it out
some of the things that they would be
able to cut really some of the only
things that they'd be able to cut our
programs that of course
disproportionately impact low income
Americans things like what's left of
welfare programs food stamps disability
energy assistance AmeriCorps Veterans
Benefits things we know Republicans love
to cut so you've got massive tax cuts
proposed for the rich they're going to
have to be paid for somehow and not
surprisingly when it's a Republican
budget they're going to be paid for by
the poor by the veterans and by the
disabled this needs to be somehow
communicated to working-class people who
voted for Donald Trump but here's the
key thing I've talked about this before
pass we've learned that one of the
failures of progressive messaging over
the last 10 15 20 years has been hey if
we just communicate the facts
Republicans will get it and then they'll
switch sides we know that doesn't work
in fact the work of people like Daniel
Kahneman and Dan Ariely and many other
behavioral economist shows us that
oftentimes being presented with opposing
facts only further entrenches someone in
their pre-existing beliefs the path
forward and people like George Lakoff
really good progressive messaging and
framing experts they've said that these
issues need to be framed to Republican
voters Trump voters as moral and ethical
problems not economic ones not ones
where we're just presenting the fact the
economic arguments that we're talking
about you know deficit neutrality
economic multiplier all that stuff it
does not work with these right wingers
this needs to be communicated as a moral
wrong and an unpatriotic thing to be
doing to make veterans injured veterans
disabled people poor single parents who
work full time making them pay for the
tax cuts for the rich it is unpatriotic
and immoral and obviously it's more
complex than I'm making it out to be but
that has to be the broad-strokes
approach here it also helps to point out
that these people may be voting against
their own interests if the poor are the
people who get screwed the most from
this budget proposal I think the
environment may come in second because
it includes a lot of cuts to the EPA
sort of like clean air programs power
plants that are clean watershed
protection and climate change research
I've read some articles arguing that you
can even make those issues issues of
climate change you can't you could
appeal to the right by making these
issues of morality and patriotism not
that I necessarily think those are the
strongest arguments but you've got to
work with what will appeal to the people
you're trying to convince yeah because I
think even some libertarians understands
that water and air don't respect the
imaginary lines that we have between
country yes and that this affects
everyone just as you know taxes do
increasingly the actual solutions to
many of the problems we're dealing with
currently are they have to be globalist
solutions and I'm not saying globalist
in the Alex Jones s conspiratorial way
of a new world order one-world
government but they need to be tackled
by countries working together an
individual country can't fix these
issues independently you have a
nationalist streak
now going on in a lot of crumpets and
you have to bridge that gap somehow and
making arguments that appeal to the
morality of these issues it might work
it's an idea I know that there are lots
of people on our reddit discussion forum
interested in this conversation I
encourage you to join us there at david
pakman.com slash reddit today's episode
of the David Pakman show is made
possible in part by Warby Parker
eyeglasses Warby Parker recently did the
right thing and ditched advertising on
right-wing conspiracy website Breitbart
pulling their ads off and you can get
the free five-day home Tryon from Warby
Parker check out their glasses I use
them when I'm not wearing contact lenses
I started with the free at-home trial
they send you five pairs of glasses you
see which ones you like you send them
back and whichever one you pick they
will put your prescription into I like
this because I can actually show the
glasses to other people and not have to
just decide on the spot like in an
eyeglass store the eyeglass industry is
controlled by very few corporations that
keep the prices very very high even over
$300 for prescription glasses with Warby
Parker they start at just 95 bucks mine
cost that including lenses and for every
pair sold they give a pair to someone in
need so to try the five pairs and
support the David Pakman show go to
Warby Parker trial comm /t DPS